y no hay que negar que una trampa a
pesar de que no es presidente y de que
no tiene un púlpito en la figura de
twitter sigue siendo una figura política
importante y que tiene grande y una gran
influencia sobre algunos legisladores de
hecho lo vimos el día de hoy aunque sí
fue un aumento un poco más el número de
senadores republicanos que se unieron a
los demócratas antes se hablaba de cinco
y hoy vemos que fueron siete en la
revista político hablaba incluso de unos
diez republicanos que podían votar
culpable o señalar de culpabilidad al
presidente ex presidente de donald trump
pero yo creo que en vista de lo ocurrido
el día de hoy pues de cierta manera le
da fuerza
a donald trump yo creo que no podemos
olvidar lo siguiente si bien el
presidente perdió por 7 millones de
votos en el voto popular
el margen de victoria de bailén y trump
viendo el colegio electoral pues
realmente fue mínimo sigue siendo una
figura importante de hecho vemos que
cada vez que los republicanos se alzaban
alza su voz en contra de donald trump
otros legisladores republicanos pues
amenazaban con que sus carreras iban a
digamos a marchitarse a no noso a no ser
digamos a no continuar su progreso y
esto lo vemos por ejemplo cuando martin
taylor greene amenazó incluso a la
representante del estado de washington
que había corroborado esa conversación
entre entre donald trump y kevin
mccarthy que es el líder de la minoría
republicana en la cámara baja así que no
sé si todavía el surja esa idea de
construir un nuevo partido porque
obviamente lo que hemos visto el día de
hoy es que con la venia de los
republicanos
donald trump sigue siendo una figura
preponderante dentro de ese partido y en
vista de que ya fue absuelto pues se
puede encaminar al 2024